good morning believe nation today's
message is become unconsciously
competent over to you jordan belfort
there were four levels of learning okay
let me tell you what the levels are some
of you might know you've been through
any self-development this is some very
basic stuff but it's important here the
first level is called being
unconsciously incompetent and what that
means is this when you first start doing
something you know so little about it
you basically know nothing you don't
know what you don't know this is a very
scary spot to be in when you're thrown
into a situation and you're a complete
novice you said geez I'd love to get
better at this but I haven't the
slightest idea what I don't know
everyone follow that concept this is
what most people start off okay the next
level is becoming consciously
incompetent that means that you're like
Jesus Christ I don't know anything
you're like I've is this does that does
that sowing strategies they also get I
don't know them that's the next level
next level above that is called being
consciously competent consciously
confident means that you're good at
something but you can't really do it
with your eyes closed yet your guru
requires all your focus and your mental
energy like we remember we were kids
growing up you'll need to tie your shoe
in the beginning you're like targets
you're like you're putting your things
across and someone says excuse me oh
good don't interrupt me you can't tie
your shoe and have a conversation at the
same time right that's when you're
consciously competent is like it
requires all your conscious focus the
next level above that is called being
unconscious competence and that means
when you're really really great at
something you can do it without thinking
about it and the only way to get from
conscious competence to unconscious
competence is through practice there's
no other way by drilling it into your
head and
again and again and again and again and
again until your brain just clicks and
all of a sudden using the unconscious
part of your mind which is infinitely
more powerful than your conscious mind
yeah I remember when I first started
learning salsa I practiced every day
literally every day when I come home
from work an hour or I came home from
school I was standing in front of the
mirror and practice to make sure my
basic it's right and I will go out every
night late literally Monday to Sunday I
go out every night to death to get
better I like I think this is why
passion is so important because when you
first start anything you're gonna suck
at it you're gonna you're gonna fail
over and over and over and over again I
need to practice to get better and the
thing that gets you through all the
feelings of sucking is a passion for
what you're doing and so whether it's
also dancing whether you're learning a
new language whether you're trying to be
an entrepreneur you know you don't have
the skills at the start you may have the
energy but you don't have the skills and
you get the skills through practicing
over and over and over and getting
better if you think about just making
these videos we made a video yesterday
on the boat and there's a bunch of
people around and here there's a bunch
of people walking around in front of us
and watching us and just getting used to
be able to do that I remember the first
time I did a video in in public I looked
around to make sure nobody was there you
know I was outside you know and now
since we've had practice it's a lot
easier and Nina's not nervous anymore as
I was nervous for Nina yesterday
thinking she would be nervous but Nina's
all these people around there I'm okay
whatever let's go do it
as Justin practiced she's been on a
number of videos I've done this over and
over and over and over again and I love
it and and so make sure you love what
you do have that strong passion and then
just practice practice practice and know
that every time you just suck a little
bit less until you start getting
actually good at what you're doing so
the question that age today is what was
the thing that you trying to get better
what are you trying to get better at
right now I like it so when you trying
to get better at right now leave it in
the comments below and we'll join the
discussions thank you so much for
watching have an amazed
they continue to believe and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shut